what does that look like somebody shows
up to you has this
buried emotional whatever emotional
suppression as you would call it how do
you work with them that because it
doesn't sound like anything that
traditional therapy would look like
absolutely not and i know you mentioned
therapy and i was going to get to that
here is the problem with talk therapy
and you just mentioned a lot of people
are like talk therapy it doesn't work
for me talk therapy is beautiful
and giving you an understanding that
there's something there
it doesn't go further and i say this
with all confidence in the world talk
therapy will not address suppress
emotional trauma it can't it's
impossible why because talk therapy
gives language and conceptualization to
the ego to the logic mind you can't heal
from the logic mind i can't sit here and
go okay i feel anger and i feel like i
want anger to come out but before i do
logically i have to pinpoint the moment
i got angry and when this happened that
doesn't matter the body doesn't care
to heal we actually need to be out of
our heads out of our mind out of logic
and into the body when we're into the
body and we allow safety
so it looks like safety to answer your
question these visits
provide
the highest amount of safety with
someone else in the room where your body
starts to go what the hell is happening
why do i feel so safe
you mean i can actually feel and then it
starts unraveling
the
safety provides the body healing the way
that it knows how to
you and i never question when your kid
is playing soccer falls on the floor and
cut his or her knee
we don't question the scab we don't
question the the new skin we don't
question the the full healing process we
just notice it
the body knows how to do the same exact
thing with emotions the problem is is
that when our compensative mechanisms
come in to protect us
that is the same thing as us picking on
that scab physically and not allowing
that wound to heal
this process
allows the body's
protective mechanisms to go on lunch
break
to go away for a little bit
and then expose those unlovable emotions
and they're unlovable not by me or not
by society but by you you deem them
unlovable you've got to be gutsy to do
that you got to be gutsy i mean i even
find that truthfully like i am terrible
at meditating i know the value of
meditation i know intellectually that
it's good for me but i have a really
hard time settling in and being able to
meditate i just there i'm blocked that's
the only way i can say it and it's
you're not black i feel loved let's say
that i
doc i feel really blocked
i'm just going to say
do you know do you know what that is
that's your compensation mechanism oh
i'm sure and i'm sure mine is like here
you know and i want to ask you about um
a little bit
related to that um a concept that's
brought to my attention a lot and
something that i felt that i felt when i
got my lyme disease diagnosis i was
really
superficially very healthy i mean it was
eating well
i got bit by a tick i didn't even notice
it i got a late stage diagnosis it sent
my body into upheaval i was functional i
was functional i was working i was on
camera at the time so people were like
oh she's fine but inside i was a mess i
had vertigo my gut was imbalanced i
crazy stuff was neurological weird stuff
was going on and one of the negative
effects of that was that i began to
distrust my body
i became this person that was then
looking at my body as i don't know this
body like i had a body i understood
before now i've had this thing go on and
there was a distrust there was a break
where i didn't know when i would
encounter something i was always like i
don't know how my body's going to handle
this i don't have the faith that i have
before and that was a huge impasse for
me that i had to overcome and i find
that a lot of people that have
autoimmune disease or are diagnosed with
i say autoimmune i don't know if they
actually have autoimmune sometimes i
think that's a diagnosis that's not
accurate in the medical establishment
because they that's what they tell you
when they don't know what's going on
sometimes they haven't really done the
digging
but regardless as to what's going on in
a person's body that's chronic
they've developed this distrust of their
body have you ever seen that in your
patients and is that something that you
feel people can overcome and that's
necessary to overcome to actually heal
the body
yeah 100
uh
an understanding of what the body's
doing is essential for healing
your body
is never failing you
your body is actually
creating the exact manifestation
of what it needs to in order to be in
balance and to continue survival your
body's only job right now is surviving
right the organism needs to survive and
it's doing everything in its process to
create that so
when you ask me about disease or anyone
ask me about disease i don't believe
disease is just a mistake i believe
disease is the body's compensative
adaptive
mechanism in order to ensure survival so
if autoimmune disease is created in the
body and listen what i said create it
not mistake there's no mistakes in the
body ever cancer is not a mistake
autoimmune disease isn't a mistake a
heart attack isn't a mistake
it is an adaptation
to the conditions that we give the body
throughout our life
so think about it this way
is hot is high cholesterol a mistake is
clogged arteries a mistake
no and here's why let's say for example
you have a really crappy diet
and your blood pressure is always up
because of inflammation and the foods
signals to the body that is causing
increased blood pressure
if you think about the inside of a blood
vessel
it's like velvet it's super super
fragile it's called the intima it's very
sensitive
and
what happens is when you have a blood
vessel and there's blood pressure just
hitting that blood vessel and and and
the movement of blood flow isn't as
smooth and flowing as it should be but
it's like
20 race cars just rubbing against it
what's going to happen the body is going
to start creating a protective mechanism
to protect the inside of the blood
vessels from blood pressure
just like
we never question this just like our
hand when we go to the gym we start
getting calluses on our hand well the
same thing happens on the inside of the
blood vessels and the inside of the
blood vessels we call that
cholesterol plaques but the cholesterol
plaque isn't a mistake that's not our
body failing us
it's a adaptation response to what you
do and what you give the body
when you think about things like
autoimmune disease or cancer those are
still adaptive responses of the body in
order to ensure survival that
cholesterol plaque is there in order to
ensure survival so the blood vessel
doesn't explode and break you understand
so if we unders if we just bring
awareness to our body is always
protecting us even if we have cancer our
body is never failing us our body is
doing everything in it that it can to
ensure survival now there's a spectrum
cancer is on the end stage spectrum
especially if it's an end-stage cancer
even though our body is working as hard
as i can to survive
you know the manifestation of tumors is
still the body's way of trying to heal
and survive but it can't anymore right
but still if you have something like
high blood pressure understand your body
is starting to create cholesterol
plaques for a reason if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]